Muhammad: Yeah, it's very important in our
work.
We have been working with women, working with
children, we are working with girls.
When we started, we encouraged families to
send their children to school, making sure
everybody went to school, girls are not left
behind.
As a result, we could achieve that 100% of
went to school.
Today we have seven and a half million [inaudible]
all over the country in Bangladesh.
And all their children are in school, and
we give them a scholarship, those who are
top performers.
And we reserve half of the scholarships for
the girls, and the other half is open for
both girls and boys.
As a result, 65% to 70% of the scholarships
go to girls because we see a tremendous impact
in the family and the person's life, in the
future of the girl.
And now we have created health -- we are in
the process of bringing healthcare where women
and children and adolescent girls will be
the focus.
Because it's very important if you can build
up the health of the women and the children
and adolescent girls, that changes the whole
scenario of the ill-health and malnutrition
and so on.
So this we want to do it.
In a way those who are the victim of the neglect
of healthcare, the real victims are again
the mother of the children and the adolescent
girls.
We'll be using the mothers and the adolescent
girls to be at the forefront of delivering
this service, so that those who are the sufferers,
they'll be the deliverers.
So this is not the professional people coming
from outside telling you what to do, they
themselves will be -- since they are the sufferers
they understand those issues so they will
be doing that.
So this is what we're looking forward to redesign
the entire healthcare system in Bangladesh.
In the same way that we have done the redesigning
of the financial system to come to the poor
people, particularly poor women.
And it will be a social business so that it
covers its cost like we did with the financial
services.
And that's what we are looking for.
I think we'll succeed.
Even the technology of it, the technology
of delivering healthcare is now possible because
amazing technology is waiting.
So the doctor doesn't have to come in physical
contact with the patients anymore, we can
make the contact possible through information
technology.
Like just now I am talking to you, using same
technology, and doctors can be doing the same
kind of thing, using information technology,
bringing all the health services to all the
people in the country.
Thank you very much